[Applause]
[Music]
when you think of Japan what is the
first thing that comes to mind you might
think of a modern and advanced country
with a rich culture or sushi many will
also think of manga video games or
samurai basically you'll likely have a
very very positive image of the Land of
the Rising Sun however as you know all
countries have their positives and they
have their negatives therefore in this
video here on visual politic we're gonna
talk about a subject that very few media
outlets talk about and that's Japan's
historical revisionism
[Music]
what exactly does that mean see we could
say that revisionism is the denial of
historical events usually negative of
course that happens in the past
so let's see what kind of people these
Japanese really are many countries that
have hard to digest past strive to hide
the truth or try and change the official
version of events and Japan definitely
one of them let's turn this around a bit
when we think of Japan in its history
what comes to mind probably samurai
geishas perhaps the double nuclear
attacker in the United States ought the
Pearl Harbor attack well at least
because of a movie to us knowing about
these events is normal but folks do we
really know how the Japanese Empire was
at the height of its power do you know
exactly what this means for the Far East
why do you think that the countries that
Japan victimized such as China and Korea
still are very susceptible to this issue
well listen up
[Music]
the Japanese Empire the Empire of Terror
you heard that right
during the first half of the 20th
century and especially during the 30s
and 40s Japan was an imperialist power
that dedicated itself to invading its
neighbors as if there was no tomorrow
and they did so with no hints of mercy
and when we say without mercy we mean it
they were truly inhumane throughout
those years Japanese troops committed
some of the most heinous abuses to human
integrity life and identity that could
ever be imagined so almost all of the
worst things we could imagine a country
doing Japan did we're talking about
terrible things like enslaving people to
work in Japan's industries and mining
enslaving women to work in brothels and
on the war fronts not to mention from
the unit 731 squad experiments in which
they used living people to conduct
chemical weapon experiments in the
Chinese city of Nanjing alone in barely
two months the Japanese killed 300,000
people and abused more than 80,000 women
it's truly a shocking history
Munson invaded a country the Japanese
Empire forcibly imposed its culture its
language and Japan's political and legal
system it even forced people to change
their names as you can see we're talking
about a dark era of uncontrolled and
unlimited fear atrocities and violence
the soldiers and the officers they could
do as they wished as a result of all of
this at least twenty million people in
Asia lost their lives at the hands of
the Japanese Empire 20 million people in
fact the data on the Japanese Army's
lack of scruples during the war give you
goosebumps check this out 40 percent of
American prisoners of war who fell into
the hands of the Japanese didn't survive
40 percent to give you an idea that
number in Europe less than 2%
and don't think that this was a
coincidence not at all the explanation
lies in the ancient Japanese culture
known as Bushido a culture that despises
soldiers who surrender in combat this
also explains why the Japanese soldiers
were so famous for fighting until the
very end but having said that let's
close the history book since Prime
Minister Shinzo Abe's rise to power in
2012 Japan has surprised the world with
a revision and denial policy of its
history that is truly disturbing but
what does it consist of what is Shinzo
are they doing to change or sugarcoat
the story our today's Japanese really
aware of their past well listen up
Shinzo Abe a revisionism in the
institutions Shinzo Abe a is already a
well-known face members of Congress I
have the high privilege and the distinct
honor of presenting to you his
Excellency
Shinzo Abe a prime minister of Japan
he's been running Japan since 2012 and
his famous particularly because of his
economic policy program better known as
abenomics back in June 1957 nobusuke
Kishi my grandfather standing right here
as Prime Minister of Japan now there is
a much more controversial aspect to
Shinzo Abe a that isn't mentioned much
in the West Lobby is an openly convinced
revisionist and the truth is that he's
always been one
[Music]
since he first entered the diet Oh
Japan's Parliament in 1993 Albert has
promoted laws and reforms that seek to
sugarcoat how the history of the
Japanese Empire is shown to society for
example in his first and brief term as
Prime Minister between September 2006
and September 2007 pavé approved a
fundamental law of education reform to
establish a more patriotic vision with
more traditionalist moral values in the
Japanese education system that is pure
nationalism in the education system and
not just that Shinzo Abe a himself as a
member of the Nippon Chi gear Japanese
ultra nationalist group founded in 1997
that openly defends historical
revisionism to exculpate of the Japanese
Empire from its crimes basically it's
kind of like if Angela Merkel belong to
an ultra radical far-right group in
Germany wouldn't really be cool but do
you think are they hides his enrollments
not at all u.s. textbook skews history
Prime Minister of Japan says
in fact guys Prime Minister are they not
only modifying the Japanese education
laws to change education of contest but
openly criticizes how Japan's history is
addressed in other countries basically
he makes no effort to conceal his bias
arby's revisionism net own goals at home
and away the Japanese Prime Minister
even attacked the mcgraw-hill publishing
house for the description that they made
of how Japan forced women to prostitute
themselves on the war front women who
for him and the revisionists were
nothing more than volunteers who earned
a lot of money although all historical
evidence does show that they were slaves
I just looked at a document McGraw
Hill's textbook and I was shocked this
kind of textbook is being used in the
United States and we did not protest the
things we should have or we failed to
correct the things we should have Shinzo
Abe a japan's Prime Minister and this
wasn't an isolated case obeys Japan
began when he started implementing the
most extreme revisionism in the
institution's driven by the ultra
nationalist group Nippon ke
[Music]
in his speech during the 70th
anniversary of Japan's surrender
are they citing the three million who
died in the Japanese Empire extolled
their sacrifices and called them
valuable had very same event by the way
the then Emperor Akihito also spoke he
of course is Hirohito son the Emperor
who attacked Pearl Harbor and unleashed
many wars across Asia well in contrast
to Shinzo are they Akito is somewhat
more embarrassed by his country's
revisionist inclination our country
today enjoys peace and prosperity thanks
to the ceaseless efforts made by the
people of Japan toward recovery from the
devastation of war and toward
development always backed by their
earnest desire for the continuation of
peace Emperor Akihito is curious that
the Emperor himself has a much more
conciliatory speech than the Prime
Minister regarding the Empire's past
[Music]
and there is more both Shinzo Abe a and
many of his party's ministers deputies
and senators regularly visit or send
offerings to that Yasukuni Shrine
yes Cooney folks is a Shinto shrine
where 14 class-a war criminals from the
Japanese Anbar among others are on it
war criminals that were declared as such
in the Tokyo trials the Japanese
equivalent to the Nuremberg trials for
the Nazis busts if you think this is all
a matter of speeches words and visits to
controversial places well you're very
very mistaken I'll listen up
[Music]
the dream of controlling education
that's right it's no secret every ruler
who aspires to change history for better
or for worse needs to influence
education we already mentioned that are
they modifying the educational law for
this purpose but he did not stop there
one of his government's biggest scandals
was that of the Asaka more atomic gakuen
nursery school you see this is a private
kindergarten school which has an
ultra-nationalist ideology yep a nursery
school with an ultra-nationalist
ideology it indoctrinates children in
the purest Japanese and past all they
even made them memorize the so-called
Imperial rescript on education of 1890
every day a kind of manifesto with the
Empire's principles all four kids who
were five and six years old
hold on a second what Russians are they
have to do with any of this well in
addition to publicly stating that he
shared the vision of the director ABBA
and his wife who by the way was named
honorary director of the nursery were
immersed in a donations and favoritism
scandal where public land was sold to
benefit the nursery the corruption
scandal almost brought down our Bay's
governments although he managed to
remain standing in the ends but besides
the imperialist nursery scandal there's
a kind of historical whitewash
throughout Japan's entire educational
system history teacher Tamaki Matsuoka
famous for having gotten 250 former
soldiers from the time of the Japanese
Empire to admit to multiple war crimes
is an expert in analyzing out Japan's
past is tackled in modern schools
Matsuoka accuses the government of
deliberately silencing the most negative
historical events of the Japanese Empire
for example in the textbooks that
students use in schools only one
footnote is dedicated to the Nanking
Massacre which we talked about at the
beginning of this video and you know I
would kind of think that an event with
300 thousand victims is probably enough
for a bit of a proper placement in a
history book
wouldn't you think but the fact that
this is happening raises an essential
question what effects could this
historical silencing have
[Music]
guys even though here on visual politic
we don't really like looking too far
back ignoring such an important part of
history can be dangerous when making
political decisions especially in a
region of the world that has so many
national feelings to make matters worse
movies books and series that the
Japanese government itself promotes feed
this idea of changing people's vision of
the past I'm referring to work such as
the eternal zero a film that highlights
the importance of the kamikaze pilots
this growing nationalism along with the
political and commercial confrontations
that have been registered in this area
of the world help explain the growing
suspicion with which young Japanese
people have begun looking of their
neighbors sociological studies state
that today 80 percent of Japanese people
have a bad image of China and sixty
percent of South Korea and that's
obviously not a good thing it's often
doing all of this what do you think
about how Japan is dealing with its past
do you think it could have consequences
maybe Japan should learn from Germany
about facing up to its history well
leave your answers in the comments below
and I really hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos also please do check out our
friends at the reconsider Media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine also as always this
channel is possible because of patreon
and our patrons on that platform please
do consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always I'll
see you next video
in June
57 novel strain CC my grandfather